America houses the largest number of
prisoners on the planet we are four
percent of the entire planet's
population and yet we have 25 percent of
the entire planet's prisoner population
in other countries where they have a
much more understanding approach that
focuses on Rehabilitation they have
better results of reintegration what is
the main difference though it's because
crime doesn't happen because people are
bad people crime for the most part is a
consequence of your material conditions
that's why when there's more poverty
like in a state like South Carolina
there's more crime reality is that we
rarely ever try to tackle the
underpinnings of why crime happens and
then we try to do this Patchwork
solution of like more police enforcement
which ironically then takes funds away
from the ways to deal with why crime
happens when there's less funding for
after-school programs When there's less
funding for Education When there's less
funding for affordable solutions to the
housing crisis the relationship that
crime has with poverty and yet for some
reason we just like to turn a blind eye
to it here in the United States